إذا مشيت مع شخص آخر
ولم يتعرفوا علي ، فهذا
هو الرجل الذي كان على خشبة المسرح في ذلك الوقت
لأن الناس أحبوا مايكل ، أريد أن
أقول إنني لست كذلك لأنهم
يقدرون مظهر الآيدول
أنهم يقدرون اسمي  هو
الجرس ، اسمي الحقيقي ميليسنت
محمد وأنا من باكستان وأنا
في هذا البلد منذ 30 عامًا وأنا
أقوم بتكريم مايكل جاكسون بشكل
احترافي منذ 20 عامًا حتى الآن
[موسيقى]
أنا في الواقع أختار ما أريد أن
أختار  على وجه الخصوص ، كان مايكل جاكسون
من قبيل الصدفة بالطريقة التي
رقصت بها في كليتي في مدرستي
، اتضح أن الجامعة هي كما تعلمون ،
اختياره للموسيقى ، قلت إنني أستطيع أن أرقص
مثله ، فلماذا لا يرتدي مثله
كان يفعل الشفاه  الغناء الذي يشبه
غناء التشغيل والغناء بالشفاه فقط
وأداء ثم خلال الفترة الزمنية التي
أردت تحسينها ، كل هذا التحسن
في المستوى التالي ، لذلك ذهبت إلى
مدربين فصول الغناء المناسبين
، والآن أغني 95 ٪ مثل
[مو  كذا]
[موسيقى]
أنت